someone has to say action or else i'm
not gonna talk action
[Music]
welcome back to making a big this is the
show where i take food that people love
and make giant versions of them what am
i doing you might ask well today we are
gonna be making a giant kitkat we have
some very expensive valrona chocolate
we've already been tempering this
chocolate for about 40 minutes with a
method known as souvit this is a machine
that keeps water
circulating at a fixed temperature this
helps the chocolate set its structure so
that it stays shiny stays snappy and if
we're going to make giant cat we might
as well do this the right way so
i'm going to keep
squishing these bags of chocolate and
giving them a nice massage and
see you guys when the chocolate's ready
okay so this chocolate is now tempered
i'm drying it off
on this towel because
water and chocolate do not get along
they hate each other we have two bags
there's more in the back
this is a small fraction
of what we're going to be using today
here we go
[Music]
this is like a chocolate waterfall
you guys see this
oh i can't say that it's okay the post
will censor it so
we managed to source
large wafers from a secret store
might have been a back room deal my
philosophy is if you don't want to know
the answer to the question
you don't ask chocolate is our glue
wafer is our paper i was never very good
in arts and crafts class but i will do
my best
yeah
let's go
let me get a smooth layer
this thing is going to take a lot of
chocolate isn't it
wow this is quite satisfying gonna fill
in all these little cracks
dang
all right
this is one
next one goes on
line it up nice
[Music]
oh little chunks
wow seems like i have a lot of work to
do and we'll be right back
that's the commercial song
after some help with the culinary team
we have 12 wafers that are all stacked
up with quite a staggering amount
chocolate i have one large knife
i have
one ruler the whole thing's around 18
inches so maybe divide that by six
pull up the woman with the numbers doing
the mean numbers here straight ish down
with a little bit of rocking
that's cool
here we go steady hand
whoa one two three four five six bricks
oh you know like in the music videos
when the rappers hold up like the money
to their ear and they're just like
i have bands and stacks
i have g's and racks
gotta get the money
because i'm flying like a honey i'm
slanging them bricks
i think that i think that means
something else though
i want to get so much for this
this is a large pullman loaf pan used
for bread making that happens to be
in the perfect size for those kit kat
signature ingots you know when you guys
open a kitkat and you see the words kit
kat on the bar itself well this is my
show i'm going to put my name we have
acetate strips commonly used in baking
or pastry to deal with cakes and things
of that sort we have honey as an edible
glue
and we have five letters and the tricky
part is that
i have to put them on backwards if we
put them on in road alvin and we flip
the kitkat over it would say
that's not my name give this a nice
little glue damn that's sticky okay
a-l-v-i-i
if i do this correctly
this should spell
alvin to the camera does it spell alvin
the pan has now been lined with our
acetate strips which means
it is time
to get this chocolate
into this pan and go in it
that's real nice i really like that
make sure we get as much of this out as
we can this is not cheap
my mom would yell at me it's gonna be my
snack it's my personal bag now i've
marked it gotta make sure there's no air
bubbles that we get all those nice
corners
oh
i can save it a little wall almost caved
in there don't do that
there you go
now we're good
don't you dare fall on me now now we can
go in with the wafer i'm gonna lay you
down just like that
try to get the edges
get you down in there too little buddy
yeah
this is set for a little bit
we're gonna get more chocolate in here
here we go
oh that's so nice
damn
this is great pop those air bubbles real
quick
these little guards seem to be uh
a little they're trying to escape their
chocolate prison so when i push them
down
just like that
i'm gonna hold these uh these wafers
under water under chocolate
until
they stop moving and struggling
that's dark i'll see you guys in a bit
so now we got one solid ingot for the
kitkat and here we have a little
contraption that our culinary team was
nice enough to put together it has a
foil and acetate setup which is where
the kit kat is going to be
finally assembled so there are six
pounds of high quality chocolate
in this bar we're just gonna try to get
this first one out
oh
tight fit in here
come out
oh is that it
that is not
it
come on
oh man that's pretty cool
oh you know what this is like this is
like when you peel the thing on the tv
and you just go in there and you get the
yeah
and then if your uh
parents are asian like mine they never
peel it off for some reason because they
think it protects it which it does but
then
it just looks ugly all right and i gotta
get my name off of this thing
give me an a
hey
give me an l
[Music]
oh
[Music]
not bad if i do say so myself
as you can see the chocolate right here
is nice and shiny which means it has
been tempered properly
damn
pretty cool huh
now i really got them bricks
i'm going to ask for some help from our
wonderful culinary team we're going to
make three of these my doctor is not
going to be very happy with me but
hey this isn't
making it healthy alright so
now the idea is to get them all together
to be one whole kitkat and we're gonna
use more chocolate
yeah buddy
all right
spread this out a bit
we've got a good base going this is
gonna be one thick kitkat
that stuff out
now we gotta get every single one of
these blocks in
ain't no way to do it
but just to do it
brick
yeah
one
look number two
ah yes
looks like i gotta make some room i'll
make it work i've done five seasons of
this show
yeah there we go
it's gonna be one thick ass kitkat i'm
gonna say
[Music]
it has been
about one hour this kit kat has been
sitting in the fridge
fingers crossed because it's time to
take it out
of walls
piece of net
big kitkat bar
there's foil underneath the kitchen
[Music]
nice
physics
last piece
i'm gonna do a little bit of this
trimming
[Music]
also called snapping
approximately 70 years later
this is a giant kitkat this weighs 30
pounds six pounds each bar and the base
itself also six pounds of chocolate a
culmination of many talented individuals
culinary team making all these bars our
team making this beautiful decoration
camera production team making this look
good on camera
and me
i just ate chocolate all day let's cut
this thing and see what you got
come on
whoa
look at that
look at that cross section and for
reference
this is a normal kit kat
this is what happens when you give a guy
like me
a lot of creative freedom
and money
give me a break
[Music]
cheers
oh ours tastes good
ours tastes
quite different
i do prefer ours because well one who
made it
and two
it costs a lot more money
i have a lot of enjoying to do
so with that being said
see you guys in the next episode or
we're going to continue
to make it big
this was really good
[Music]
you